what we find is very often the truer a  statement is the more liable it is to  incur the ire of cancel culture cancel  culture is political correctness with  teeth political correctness is the  leftist speech codes and behavior codes  that we all make fun of because they're  so ridiculous  cancel culture is the mutant spawn of  political correctness cancel culture is  what happens when you contradict those  codes of speech and behavior that  political correctness dictates  PC and cancel culture threaten our  public discourse they stifle speech they  stifle thought worst of all they  encourage lies we must fight both of  those scourges tooth and nail  we must do it we must not be forced to  live in lies we must not be forced to  live in fear  nobody benefits from living in lies  nobody benefits from living in fear  we're told that they do they don't